[Musica]
allora in tanto facevo una riflessione
in queste in questi dodici più 12 minuti
l'età di sofia e di paolo sommate non
fanno la mia quindi questo vi dice che
ragazzi se avete questa avete fatto che
sta grandissima queste grandissime cose
in così breve tempo
ecco quando arriverete la mia età che
over la vostra combinata
mi aspetto di partecipare non protegge e
ascoltare quello che avete fatto
oggi parliamo di football dei futures
non vi parlerò di quale sarà la nuova
nutella non vi parlerò di quale sarà i
nuovi rossetti che cosa faremo anche
perché vorrei parlare un po di più di
quello che l'approccio che un po tutto
il mondo food and beverage sta prendendo
a quello che si chiama fondamentalmente
fotografici mi sono innamorato di questo
tema mi sono innamorato del tema del
football
dieci anni fa ero in un momento
abbastanza complesso della mia carriera
professionale è uno di quei momenti
capiterà a tutti dove un'esperienza
lavorativa va male un'altra non va
benissimo
perdi le certezze e non avere non hai
più con la visione non sai più
effettivamente dove andare quello che
devo fare next quali sono le leghe le
cose successive che ti possono
interessare perdi un attimo la visione
fino a quando poi sono stato chiamato un
giorno dal da patrick firmenich che è il
sì o il proprietario di un'azienda che
lavora nell'ambito dell'innovazione del
food del ingredienti stica per un
colloquio
e lì ho capito quello che c'è dietro il
food ho capito quanta innovazione c'è
dietro il food per cui dieci anni dopo
quando poi ho incontrato a a
nel lussemburgo dottor giovanni ferrero
che mi chiedeva ma nel 2030 nel 2040
cosa si mangerà che cosa mangeremo qual
è l'obiettivo a cui dobbiamo lavorare
ecco quella volta con giovanni ferrero
abbiamo parlato di questo oggetto
abbiamo parlato di food e fiducia
parlando di lente a contatto e spesso la
metto qui perché capirete che cosa
fondamentalmente vuol dire tutto questo
quando si parla del futuro difficile
abbiamo tantissime cose che ci vengono
dette si parla di slice e mick index si
parla di block chain si parla di digital
biology
avrete sentito quelle cose che dicono
che oggi noi siamo 3 miliardi di cellule
ma abbiamo quasi 9 miliardi tra batteri
funghi e virus all'interno del nostro
corpo per cui il metabolismo
non è dato da come mangiamo da quello
che mangiamo mai dato fondamentalmente
da questi altri 9 miliardi di esseri che
ci vivo addosso non siamo cellule siamo
forse più il resto che cellule parola
fine dice che cosa vuol dire che cosa
effettivamente vuol dire food al
deflusso è quello e questo solo dobbiamo
chiedere che cosa cambierà radicalmente
il mondo del food nei prossimi dieci
venti trent'anni non un cambiamento
lineare un cambiamento esponenziale e
per capire come avvengono i cambiamenti
esponenziali
bisogna sempre sapere che le innovazioni
quelle breakthru quelle che cambiano il
mondo nascono sempre a di hedges nascono
sempre là dove ci sono delle cose che
non sembrano avere una grande rilevanza
col mercato che uno a ma che poi
cambieranno tutto mi spiego questa è una
mappa del 1453 quella in blu altro non è
che la rotta che seguirono le spezie che
andavano da east verso est e che
venivano utilizzate nella parte west del
mondo non per condire cv ma per
conservare erano costosissime erano
assolutamente a privilegio beneficio
solo di alcuni
e vediamo utilizzare per conservare gli
dicevo fino a quando qualche anno dopo
qualcuno
sul lago michigan scoprì che
fondamentalmente facendo dei blocchetti
di ghiaccio e naturalmente prodotti la
madre natura si poteva conservare da
quel momento il mondo delle spezie fu
completamente spazzato via
non esisteva più il concetto spezia
uguale conservazione
anzi l'opposto e questo signore francis
tudor nel 1806 comincio a pensare come
spostare ghiaccio addirittura da east
sole per solida west quindi dalle nostre
aree verso pista era cambiato tutto
quindi il mondo delle spezie spazzato
dal viaggio questo ci fa capire che cosa
vuol dire il che l'innovazione va al dl
se quello che noi tutti quanti noi oggi
nelle grandi aziende
andiamo a pensare esattamente questo
come assolutamente dobbiamo cambiare il
mondo
il consumatore il consumatore
siamo noi siamo lo sappiamo siamo siamo
connessi siamo digital
siamo curiosi diamo informazioni su
tutto non vi parlerò delle ultime
informazioni sull'olio di palma che
aveva danno i consumatori che non sono
assolutamente corretti ma questo andiamo
avanti
il consumatore comunque è il conscious
il consumatore è un experience che in
cina il nostro business per 30 per cento
è fatto con quello che si chiama m
commerce neanche i com sempre fatto con
un cellulare fondamentalmente quindi il
consumatore sta cambiando radicalmente
st shift andò completamente il suo modo
di pensare
poi abbiamo gli ingredienti che abbiamo
nel cibo fino a oggi noi abbiamo pensato
all'ingrediente come un inglese che deve
far bene
un ingrediente questo è quello che c'è
nella superficie tutti quanti voi oggi
pensate ingredienti siano sostenibili
che siano naturali che siano salutari
però si sta cominciando a capire che
l'importanza di un ingrediente è anche
l'impatto che ha nel nostro sistema
metabolico
non tutti gli ingredienti sono uguali
per tutti
non tutti i cibi fanno bene o male
sapere se sono queste
questo no i ricettori che abbiamo nella
lingua e che lavorando in coppia il
genero il segnale di dolce al nostro
cervello quando una molecola di zucchero
scolpisce queste 22 ricettori insieme
c'è un segnale che parte al cellulare
dice c'è dolcezza il segnale dipende da
quanto questi ricettore si aprono e si
chiudono quindi tutto lo zucchero che
noi ingeriamo e che non colpisce i
ricettori che cosa fa
ma nel nostro sistema va nel nostro
stomaco lo scendiamo c'è il glucosio che
entra nel sangue quando il glucosio
arriva dei livelli alti
il pancreas manda il guardiano insulina
nel sistema e dice alle cellule
assorbite questo cui costo in più
purtroppo quando il picco glicemico e
alto il fegato che dovrebbe catturare il
pesto caso che ricordano per poi
rilasciarlo come energia dopo non ce la
fa più e cosa succede tutto problema in
eccesso diventa grasso quindi quando
parliamo noi gli ingredienti dobbiamo
parlare fondamentalmente pensando che un
ingrediente deve essere buono ma
contemporaneamente non deve farci male
e qui arriva la tecnologia cosa c'entra
la tecnologia col cibo beh riprendo le
lenti a contatto e quel discorso avuto
il 14 settembre del 2014 con il dottor
giovanni in lussemburgo
la tecnologia aiuterà fortemente è
fondamentalmente lo sviluppo del food
oggi stiamo lavorando si sta lavorando
ad una lente a contatto che abbia della
tecnologia elettrone incapsulata e
attraverso gli della le lacrime
riuscirà a mandare dei segnali e ci dirà
qual è la variazione di glucosio che noi
abbiamo nel sangue quindi in tempo reale
noi potremo sapere immediatamente il
cibo che stiamo mangiando che tipo di
impatto ha sul nostro metabolismo
se è nell'aria lo se nell'area miyu mese
la reali se nell'era lupo di che ci fa
bene non abbia nessun problema
[Musica]
me lo aspettavo però è così
la realtà è questa la realtà è questa la
nutella ha un impatto per c'è un filo di
di 45 adesso è provato ecco quindi la
tecnologia ci darà l'opportunità di
capire quello che stiamo mangiando
ed ecco perché comincerà a diventare
possibile finalmente la definizione in
una dieta personalizzata persone
ciascuno di noi dovrà e potrà costruirsi
la propria dieta non sulla base di
quelle che sono
genova guidelines ma sulla base di
quelle che sono effettivamente impatti
sul nostro sistema del cibo che mangia
siamo tutti quindi lavorando in questo
modo stiamo lavorando per capire come
tutto questo cambierà il nostro mondo
per cui quando uno mi chiede ma che cosa
fare industria sul food d'ufficio si
lavoriamo sul meno zucchine o palm oil
gas pomodori uomo ma lui
fondamentalmente crediamo in modo molto
molto forte che il sud deficere altro
non è che l'integrazione e la
interrelazione costante tra il
consumatore
l'ingrediente la tecnologia il
consumatore chiederà la tecnologia quali
ingredienti mangiare gli ingredienti
suggeriranno alla tecnologia che cosa
far mangiare al consumatore
e questo il 5 ecco perché noi stiamo
spendendo tanta attenzione su quello che
sta avvenendo nell'area della tecnologia
questo è il frutto che facciano però
e questo perché in tutti noi stiamo
facendo però attenzione una cosa
importante se noi ci guardiamo intorno
cerchiamo anche di capire che non è solo
un discorso del food rifugio oggi noi
abbiamo un problema molto serio molto
forte che si chiama povertà che sia la
malnutrizione
oggi noi tra food waste and food loss
combinandoli insieme abbiamo quasi un
miliardo e 300mila tonnellate di cibo
che sprechiamo basterebbero un quarto di
quel miliardo e trecentomila tonnellate
affamare le 900.000 persone al mondo che
non possono mangiare per cui quando
parliamo di food e fusion
quando parliamo di futuro quando
parliamo di tecnologia eco attenzione
dobbiamo sempre tener conto che la vita
il bilanciamento la vita ai link ayane
la vita e andare avanti ma evitare che
una parte della popolazione rimanga
dietro perché tutto questo noi non ce lo
potremmo permettere il food di futures e
anche un grandissimo impegno per far sì
che chi oggi non mangi domani lo potrà
fare
grazie
[Applauso]